no I've never read the Terms of Service
I have not no I have never I've never
entered service they own me I don't even
know why never but nothing personal I'd
never read the terms of payment or
anything it's really kind of a crazy
thing to assume that someone is going to
click I accept having fully understood
what's going on I think the single most
important page if you're going to pick
one to read well there's two is the
Terms of Service and the data policy are
these kind of two top pages because this
dictates your agreement with Facebook
okay Terms of Service this agreement was
written in English
ha they extend any translated version of
this agreement conflicts with the
English version the English version
controls please note that section 16
contains different of rights and
responsibilities terms for SRS the
principles in this our nurse our
relationship with users and others are
using or accessing the Facebook services
you agree to read the data policy and to
use it to help you make informed
decisions there was a data policy should
we read the dinner policy wanna read the
data Balki let's do it
nobody's ever run the data policy I
haven't
people who broke through that apology
aprenden that apology damn policy we
give you the power to share ass all caps
- this is all in caps this is in all
capital letters all screaming at you we
try to keep Facebook up bug free and
safe but you use it at your own risk
yelling at us just because it's all cat
says I mean I'm gonna read it in fact
because it's all caps
I'm just skip it like I skip the recipe